Magic on this earth Crystals of human wisdom All lost magical
power That power is inviting into it
Resurrection The
world was overflowing
with magic  Descendants
Being a magician is an identity My
magical power is 9 from the
world Becoming the world's only Playsaps magician The
path to becoming a magician is not defiled
[music]
car
[applause]
What's wrong,
cleft lip-chan, why are you fighting?
This time, you really
want to erase all magical power and the existence of magicians from this world Ahhhhh
[Music] The
only princess in the world is a magician  If
it's possible to
become one, then I thought I'd give
it a try.  No,
Ikuya Who put the curse on that doll
?  If it may be, a little